wir gehen jetzt weiter mit der These von
Herrn Bosbach und zwar ist ja mit der
Ampel noch was anderes los als vorher
greifen ja das schließt genau daran ich
mache mir Sorgen um die politische die
wirtschaftliche und die soziale
gesellschaftliche Stabilität in unserem
Land meiner Beobachtung nach regiert die
Ampel stramm an den Themen vorbei die
für die Bevölkerung wirklich von großer
Bedeutung ist ich stelle eine
erschreckende realitätsferne fest um auf
das Thema heizungsgesetz zu kommen ich
habe mich maßlos geärgert über den Satz
in der Theorie sind die Leute alle für
Klimaschutz nur wenn es konkret wird
dann kneifen sie dann wollen sie das
nicht das ist eine Frechheit dem
gegenüber die sich große wirtschaftliche
ja gerade zu existenzielle Sorgen machen
und diese Sorgen sind nicht herbeife
fantasiert sondern sie sind Folge eines
völlig unausgegorenen Gesetzentwurfes
selbst wenn man jetzt sagt wir Federn
aber die sozialen Härten ab wissen wir
noch gar nicht wer in welcher Form
eine Zuwendung des Staats beim
Heizungstausch bekommen wird
offensichtlich gibt es eine Regierung
die an sich werden Haushalt ist reich
völlig falsch ich kenne genügend Leute
die haben sie ihr Leben lang krumm
gelegt um sich den Traum vom kleinen
Häuschen erfüllen zu können und wenn du
jetzt älter bist und es Rentnerin
Rentner stehst du mit dem Rücken an die
Wand da weißt du nicht was kommt jetzt
auf mich zu die sorgen muss ich ernst
nehmen da kann ich nicht sagen ja euch
fehlt das richtige ökologische
Bewusstsein ein ähnliche Lage haben wir
bei der Migrationspolitik wenn die
Innenministerin sagt
Humanität kennt keine Obergrenze sagt
sie damit wir haben eine völlig
grenzenlose Aufnahme und
Integrationskraft in unserem Land die
haben wir nicht viele Städte und
Gemeinden unseres Landes sind heute
schon
überfordert mit dem was auf sie zukommt
und Berlin lässt sie hier alleine wenn
Berlin die Grundsatzentscheidung trifft
es bleibt so wie es in den letzten
Jahren war da muss Berlin auch den
Städten und Gemeinden die Kosten
erstanden
also die CDU führt ja jetzt auch nicht
gerade alle Umfragen an Wand an warum
schafft ihre Partei ist nicht ein
Gegenprogramm zu bieten worauf die
Menschen auch Vertrauen genau das
erwachte ich von der Union dass sie
nicht nur Kritik übt um der Kritik
Willen oder um die Regierung kritisieren
zu können dass ja nur eine Aufgabe der
Opposition ich erwachte auch dass wir
alternativ Vorschläge unterbreiten
deswegen arbeite ich hier auch zum
Beispiel im Rahmen meiner bescheidenen
Möglichkeiten beim Grundsatzprogramm der
CDU mit wenn auch im Bereich innere
Sicherheit ja haben sie recht es genügt
nicht im Parlament Nein zu sagen sondern
gerade von der Union wird auch erwartet
dass sie sagt was sie denn an der Stelle
der Regierung besser machen würden
Schmerzen nein ich weiß das ist im
Moment ein sehr sehr schwerer Spagat für
für ihn viele waren ja sehr sehr
skeptisch als er gewählt worden ist aus
der Führung in den Mitglieder bei den
Mitgliedern war er immer der haushohe
Favorit im es täglichen sah das anders
aus und jetzt versucht er ist beiden
Seiten rechts zu machen was nicht
einfach ist man kann auch sagen er liebt
mit den Grünen weil er wahrscheinlich
Schwarz-Grün haben will bei nächsten
Wahl ja darauf kommt es aber nicht
entscheidend an entscheidend ist das
Votum der Wählerinnen und Wähler in
Nordrhein-Westfalen gestritten dass er
mit den Grünen die beugelt nein ich habe
ja selber mal geschrieben ich habe mir
selber mal geschrieben manche Kritik
fällt sehr moderat aus weil man sich
offensichtlich die Grünen nicht
vergraulen möchte aber mein Nachbar hat
ja gerade das Gegenteil gesagt
Beispiele dass er mit den Grünen
liebäugel ich sehe da tatsächlich das
Gegenteil also er ich finde die direkt
an gegenüber den Grünen wird immer
härter von friesoy ja aber das sehe ich
gar nicht so ich bin ja schon mal froh
dass er Bosbach am am Grund des Programm
arbeitet oder sollten sie aber dann
tatsächlich mit ihren Kollegen und
Parteifreunden sprechen weil tatsächlich
ein bisschen mehr Substanz von der Union
wäre da bin ich bei ihnen schon
förderlich im übrigen ich teile sehr
viele Punkte die sie gerade genannt
haben mit bezüglich des ähm der
Finanzierung geht nicht jeder der ein
Haus hat ist reich und dann wenn wir es
nicht schaffen wenn wir es nicht
schaffen die soziale Komponente und die
ökologische Komponente miteinander
gemeinsam ergreifen verlieren wir auf
allen Ebenen dann verlieren dann werden
die Menschen nämlich auch mit den Füßen
abstimmen und wir wissen uns das
umweltpolitisch dann eben nicht geholfen
da das teile ich auch unser Problem ist
aber auch ein Stück weit das 16 Jahre
lang eben jegliche Reform auf allen
politischen Ebenen die relevant sind wir
werden ja später ja auch noch mal über
den Lehrermangel sprechen und an
überhaupt Arbeitskräftemangel komplett
ignoriert worden
nur alleine regiert oder in diesem Land
absolut dabei ist als stärkster Partner
erwartet man ja natürlich
erneuerbare Energien die Union
angetreten ist 2005 und wie hoch der
Anteil war als sie nach 16 Jahren Angela
Merkel dann das ganze wer hat das
entscheidende Gesetz für die erneuert
nein doch das erneuerbare
Energiegesetzes
gestern
reicht aber nicht es reicht an dieser
Stelle nicht ich weiß noch welche
Schlagabtausch innerhalb der großen
Koalition
die SPD mit der Union diesbezüglich
hatte und die Union zum Jagen tragen
musste und wie sie kritisieren sehr
viele Punkte in Atomausstieg über Nacht
den wir hatten ohne dass das zu Ende
durchdacht worden ist wie wir das
kompensieren können wir haben einen
Söder der das Fähnchen nach dem Wind
legt ohne nachzudenken wir haben kein
sie können doch jetzt gestalten machen
mit zwei anderen Koalitionspartnern die
sich regelmäßig die Körper einschlagen
und dann muss die SPD dann teilweise
auch den Kindergärtner spielen an dieser
Stelle und sie haben mir gerade gesagt
wie die FDP sich an dieser Stelle
benimmt die Grünen haben auch ihre
Problemchen und dann muss es halt jemand
mit der ruhigen Hand und mit guter
Politik richten das ist Urlaub und der
kann aber nicht an allen Stellen im
Feuer löschen auf jeden Fall wenn der
Urlaub Scholz ein Fleisch Heftchen hat
kriegen sie heute ganz viel Punkte also
da das haben Sie heute schon gesagt
stimmt zwei ist schon schwierig drei
pachten in der Koalition hatten wir auf
Bundesebene noch nie das ist doch das
Dreifache Problem Olaf Scholz einen
guten Job er macht das Verein auch für
ihn schwierigen Situationen das beste
insbesondere bei der Frage Ukraine hilfe
ich kann verstehen dass er zögert ich
kann verstehen dass er jede Entscheidung
gut abwägt weil keine unrisiken und
Nebenwirkungen ist das kann ich
verstehen und mit der berühmten Faust
auf den Tisch schlagen ist bei einer
Dreierkoalition schon mal gar nichts ist
egal ob du größer oder kleine Partei ist
wenn die drei nicht mehr zusammen können
ist eine Koalition am Ende meiner
Erfahrung nach ist es eher wenn die
persönlichen Verhältnisse zerrüttet sind
an einzelnen Sachfragen scheitern
Koalition nicht der besteht die Ampel
aktuell da kurze Einschätzung
von Tag zu Tag
ein Schauspiel was wir da erleben ich
würde zustimmen dass Olaf Scholz
versucht diese wirklich nicht einfache
Melange einigermaßen gut durch diverse
Krisen zu führen der Eindruck ist auch
dass er eigentlich zunehmend nicht mehr
auf das unbedingt hört was seine Partei
von ihm will sondern dass er das macht
er für das Land für richtig erachtet und
auch das sieht sicherlich pragmatisch
immer unter dem unter dem Gesichtspunkt
sieht wie schafft er es dann auch wieder
gewählt zu werden seine beliebtheitswert
und jeder SPD sind derzeit nicht die
besten also da ist noch sehr viel Luft
nach oben bis mutmaß nicht Herbst 20 25
aber natürlich gibt es zwei Partner die
überhaupt nicht zusammenpassen da sind
die Grünen oder sind die FDP die passen
vor der Wahl nicht zusammen und die
passen auch jetzt nicht zusammen und mit
jedem Tag mit dem die Koalition länger
zusammenarbeitet werden diese Risse und
dieses diese unterschiedliche Auffassung
auch zur Staatsverständnis die Art und
Weise wie man eine Marktwirtschaft sieht
wie man das Thema soziales definiert
diese Unterschiede die gab es vorher und
die gibt es auch weiterhin braucht man
nur die Parteiprogramme nebeneinander zu
legen und die werden halt mit jedem Tag
immer sichtbarer und das giftige
Giftpfeile fliegen von den Grünen zu den
Liberalen und von den Liberalen zu den
Grünen und zwischendrin sitzt Olaf
Scholz mal Doktor sich mal lässt er die
Pfeile auch auf aber
wir haben es einfach mit drei sehr sehr
unterschiedlichen Parteien zu tun grün
und FDP sind die die weitesten Pole
würden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie